At the end of last class,
I quoted some words from Kurt Vonnegut,
uh,
kind of,
death deathbed prayer confession that he'd written in one of his novels in which
the basic gist of the,
uh,
prayer is to express gratitude of Howard whatever the content of your life,
the fact that at least you've been able to live at all as he put it,
most mud isn't lucky enough to sit up.
He feels lucky to have been some of the city and up mud.
He loved everything he saw.
When I read that quote,
I did not know that Kurt Vonnegut had died the night before.
Um,
immediately after the class ended,
a visitor to the class brought this fact to my attention.
So I can't pass without commenting on that death.
And just remark that I hope that till the very end,
Kurt Vonnegut who lived till he was 84,
uh,
realized how lucky he was to be some of the city not mud.
All right.
The question I want to turn to now is this.
So we've been going over the various facts about the nature of life and death.
And the question then is how should we live in light of the fact that we're
going to die?
Previously we've talked about what emotional response we should have to that.
And I've argued as I've just reminded us that,
uh,
although perhaps the most common reaction is one of fear or terror at death,
it may in fact be that we should be grateful and consider ourselves lucky that
we're able to have had life as well life at all.
But how then should we live in light of the fact that we're going to die?
And the immediate answer that comes to mind,
it seems almost like a joke.
Uh,
I want to say,
well,
we should be careful.
Um,
given that one kid,
we can die,
that we will die.
They used to be a TV show,
a cop show called Hill street blues.
The show began every day with the sergeant sort of going over the various crimes
and investigations that,
uh,
we're going to sort of fill up,
the days,
the days episode.
And he'd always end as he sent off his police,
uh,
his,
the cops,
he,
and by saying,
be careful,
be careful out there,
but the particular kind of care that I have in mind isn't just this sheer fact
that,
you know,
if you're not careful,
you'll,
you won't notice that the cars coming down the street and you'll get hit by the
car and that'll be the end.
The fact that we're going to die intuitively seems to require a particular kind
of care because as we might put it,
you only go around once,
right?
Uh,
you don't get,
you don't get to do it again.
And so it seems as though the fact that we're mortal,
the fact that we've got a finite lifespan requires us to face the fact that
intuitively we can blow it.
We could do it wrong.
Now the,
the nit picky part of me wants to point out that it can't be mortality per se,
that has this implication.
Even if we lived forever,
we could still do it wrong.
After all,
whatever it is you filled your life with,
with an immortal,
infinite life,
they're still going to be that particular pattern of actions and activities that
you engage in.
And that particular pattern could still be one that wasn't the best pattern that
was available to you.
So the,
the possibility of having blown it,
of having lived the wrong kind of life is a possibility that's going to be true
of us.
Whether or not we're mortal,
and yet for all that,
it seems as though mortality adds an extra risk and extra danger of blowing it.
Look,
it's supposed to be lived forever and just have a kind of simplistic example.
You might say,
imagine somebody who spends his eternity counting the integers,
one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six.
Well that might not be as valuable as an eternity spent doing something else.
Let's say,
uh,
doing more complicated math,
but still if you've spent a million years or a billion years counting the
integers and then realized that was sort of pointless,
you could always start over by doing more interesting,
more deep,
more worthwhile math.
The immortality gives you a chance of starting over,
gives you the possibility of do overs.
We might then worry that what's especially bad about death,
the fact that we're mortal is that it robs us of the chance of do overs.
But of course that's not quite right either.
I mean,
even if you don't live forever,
you live 80 years or 100 years,
you have the chance to reappraise your life at the age of 20 or 30 or 50 and
decide you need to change course.
So it's not exactly as though the possibility of do overs disappears by death
itself via death itself.
Still the thought that death comes when it does seems to push us in the
direction of thinking.
We've still got to be very careful because of course getting that we're mortal,
we have only a limited period of time in which to do the do overs.
There are,
there are two kinds of mistakes really that we might catch ourselves in.
We might discover on the one hand that we made some bad choices in terms of what
we were aiming for and on the other hand we might find even if we made the right
choices in terms of our goals,
we flubbed it in terms of actually accomplishing what we were trying to
accomplish and so we've got,
we literally have to start over again and try again.
So there's two kinds of care that we have to take.
We have to be careful in our aims and we have to be careful in our execution of
our aims because we have as it were,
a rather limited amount of time to do it over.
Now again,
the nit picky part of me wants to say strictly speaking,
it's not the fact that we are mortal per se.
That all by itself means we have to be especially careful after all.
Suppose there just weren't all that many things worth doing and suppose they
weren't all that complicated,
all that difficult to do well.
So those are the only five things worth doing.
And even if you couldn't necessarily do every single one of them right the first
time out at most it would take two or three tries and buy a try.
I mean maybe an hour or two.
Well that'd be a pretty impoverished world that could only offer us that much.
But after all,
if that was the way the world works and we had a hundred years,
we wouldn't really have to worry all that much about being careful.
We'd have plenty of time to aim for each of the five things worth having and
plenty of time to get each one of the five things right.
A hundred years of life would be more than enough.
We wouldn't have to be careful.
So it's not just the fact that we're mortal that requires us to be careful.
It's the fact that we have a relatively short span of life relative to how much
there is worth aiming for and how complicated and difficult it can be to get
those things and get them right.
It's because of the fact that there's so much to do and doing it properly that
we have to be careful.
We just don't have enough time to sort of flail around and try a little of this,
try a little of that.
Somebody who lives like that may well find that the things they aimed for war,
really the best choices.
You don't have to decide that these things weren't worth having at all given the
relatively short period of time we've got.
We've got the extra burden of deciding what are the things most worth going
after and we have to face the prospect that chance that we will look back and
discover that we didn't make the best choices there.
We aimed for the wrong things,
not necessarily things that weren't worth having,
but given the limited number of things where we were going to be able to fill
our lives with in that sense the wrong choices.
And we may discover as well that we were not sufficiently careful,
attentive in how we tried to achieve these things because it's not as though,
although given the way life is,
you've got the chance for do overs,
you don't have time for a whole lot of do overs.
And so what death forces us to do is to be careful and analogy that comes to
mind here is a,
an artist who goes up,
musician who goes into a recording studio and look,
he can start trying to record his songs to cut an album.
Uh,
and he may only have a certain number of songs in his repertoire.
And so if he's got a long enough period of time a month in the recording studio,
he's got plenty of time where she's got plenty of time to sing a couple of
songs.
Maybe these wouldn't be the best things to record.
Let's give it a try and we'll see.
Didn't get it right the first take.
Let's record it again.
Let's try it a third time.
Let's try it a fourth time.
If you've got enough time,
it's less pressing to get clear before you start.
Or as you're going along,
what are the songs I should try to record and can I get it on one take or at
most two,
but if instead of having a month in the recording studio,
you've got only a week in the studio or a day in the studio,
suddenly everything's much more pressing.
Time is much more precious.
You've got to decide early on just which are the songs that it makes sense to
record and yeah,
there were some other songs,
but these seem to be the better choices and when you record them,
you can't be as careless and inattentive as you try to get them down.
You've got to try to get it right the first time or at worst the second time.
That's it seems to me the situation we find ourselves in,
not just given the fact that we die,
but we might say given how incredibly rich the world is,
how many things it offers us,
how many choices we have in terms of what's worth going after,
but for many of these things,
given how difficult they are to accomplish,
although we've got the chance for do overs,
both in terms of changing our mind about what we should be aiming at and trying
again for the things we have aimed debt,
we've got to be careful.
The fact about our death requires paying attention.
It requires care.
Well,
having said that,
of course they needed question that has,
all right,
so,
so I'm paying attention,
I'm,
I'm trying to be careful.
What should I do with my life?
How,
how shall I,
what should I fill it with?
We've previously in the class talked about the possibility that being alive per
se may have some value,
but w above and beyond whatever standard we take on that certainly also the case
that part of what adds to the value of our lives are the contents of our lives
and so we need to ask,
well,
what kinds of contents should we try to fill our lives with?
Now I won't try to answer that to to ask the question,
what are the things really worth going after in life is to come up to the edge
of asking,
well,
just what is the meaning of life?
What's really worth going after and although that is indeed an important perhaps
the important question,
it's the question I think for a different class and so having come close to the
edge of that question,
I'm going to now back away from it,
but still it seems we might say in broad strokes there are two different
strategies that we could adopt and it's worth at least pause and to think about
these two strategies.
Strategy Number One says,
given that you've only got a finite amount of time,
actually the basic underlying thought,
hi,
both strategies,
it's just this haven't gotten much time pack as much as you can into life pack
as much as,
as much as you can in.
But there are two basic strategies about how to put that idea to practice.
And strategy number one says,
given the dangers of failure,
if you aim to ambitiously,
you should settle for the kinds of goals that you're virtually guaranteed that
you'll accomplish.
The pleasure is a food
company,
sex,
ice cream.
Uh,
one of the paper topics a asks you to reflect on the philosophy,
eat,
drink,
and be merry for tomorrow.
You Die.
Well,
that's one of the strategies.
All right,
we're going to be dead tomorrow.
And so while we're here,
let's try to pack in as much as we can by going for the things that we've got a
very high chance of actually accomplishing.
Strategy number two says,
well,
that's all well and good.
You've got a pretty high chance of succeeding at that.
The trouble with strategy.
Number one is the goods that you can achieve,
the sort of shore thing.
Goods are small,
they're rather small potatoes as things go.
Some of the most valuable goods in life are things that don't come so readily.
Don't come with guarantees of achieving them.
You might want to write a novel compose a symphony or for that matter,
res marry and a family.
Some of these things,
strat fans,
a strategy number to argue these things are the most valuable things that life
can offer us so that a life filled with these larger goods is a more valuable
life than a life filled with the small potatoes.
Goods,
I suppose fans of the eat,
drink and be merry strategy.
Don't like to call those small potatoes goods,
but that's the kind of language that might be offered by fans.
A strategy number two,
and it seems to me that as a clean about which life,
if only you had it,
if you had a guarantee,
you know,
if God were going to say,
look,
which life do you want?
I promise you'll get it.
The life filled with food and drink or the life filled with accomplishment.
Okay.
Perhaps most of us would say,
well,
it's the life filled with accomplishment.
That's the more valuable life.
The trouble of course is the life with the greater accomplishments.
The like aiming for greater accomplishments is also a life with a greater chance
of failure.
You aim for writing the great American novel and 10 years later you still
haven't finished it in 20 years later you decide you don't have it in you to
write the great American novel.
Okay.
You try to produce a business and it goes under.
Okay,
so what's the right strategy to take?
I suppose many of us would be inclined to say,
well,
the third strategy,
there's a third strategy.
That's the obvious league right thing to do,
which is get the right mixture,
aim for a certain number of,
what should we call it?
Large potatoes gave for a certain number of the large accomplishments because if
you do manage to get them,
your life will have more value,
but also throw in a certain sprinkling of the smaller things where you're at
least assured of having gotten something out of life.
Well,
that's all well and good as well,
but adjust now brings us to the next question.
What is the right mixture after all?
Well,
I'm not going to try to answer that one either,
but again,
those of you who choose the topic that eat,
drink and be merry question.
Basically I'm inviting you in that topic to reflect on that question.
Here's a different thought.
The entire,
as they said,
the underlying thought behind the the,
you know,
go for the big things.
Go for the small things,
was pack it all in.
The underlying thoughts seem to be,
well,
look you,
as long as you've got a life that's got valuable contents,
the more the better.
We might say,
here's common ground between the two strategies.
The more the better.
Now,
previously we've,
I've argued that in mortality would not actually be a good thing.
Eventually rich and incredible as the world is eventually the goods of life
would run out and immortality would be dreadful.
But having said that,
that's not to suggest that we,
most of us come remotely close to that condition.
For most of us,
it's certainly true that you know,
dying at 30 deprives you of goods that would have come to you if only you'd live
to 40 and dying at 40 deprives you of goods that would have come to you if only
you'd live to 50 or 60 or 80 so one thing that we're inclined to agree is know
other things being equal,
the longer your life,
the better.
So
here's a life 50 years long
and suppose you live it with a certain amount of value in your life,
a hundred value points,
whatever that is,
whatever,
whatever the however our units of measuring just how good our life is,
we say,
look,
better to have a life at that value instead of going through 50 years went for a
hundred years.
Fair enough.
We might say we all agree,
don't we?
That quantity of life a good thing.
And that does seem plausible,
but at the same time a want to immediately say quantity of life may matter,
but it's not the only thing that matters.
Quality of life matters as well and again that points fairly uncontroversial.
You had to choose between your life at 50 years at a hundred value points.
Okay.
Or 50 years.
Yeah,
whatever that is 130 value points you'd rather have the second life.
The length of life isn't the only thing we care about.
The overall quality of your life is something we care about as well.
And this of course is another topic that we've talked about previously.
Just what is it that goes into making a life better than another.
So we now sort of see summing it up yet got to pay attention to quality,
got to pay attention to quantity or duration.
Of course he's not just corrected myself as,
because you might say if you want to think about it mathematically,
it all is just a matter of quantity.
As long as when we measure quantity,
we bear in mind we need to measure not just the,
the length of the life,
but the height of the box.
So the area of the box here is 50 times a hundred units.
So whatever that is,
that's a 5,000
yeah.
Going to get another giggle here.
Right.
You know,
we sort of imagine a little units,
it's a,
you know,
it's a quality one unit of quantity,
one unit of quality for a year.
So it's a quality year unit,
whatever it is,
5,000 units
here,
6,500
right?
Say,
look,
we can capture the thought that the duration of your life matters.
The quality of your life matters by,
by multiplying the two together.
And without getting hung up on the numbers,
there's no,
there was anything kind of precision here.
The underlying thoughts,
fairly clear.
The area of the box represents the overall quality,
the overall quantity that you've managed to cram into your life and your 50
years.
And we could,
we could start measuring different kinds of lives.
We might start worrying about,
well look,
suppose I could live 50 years at 130 or I could live,
you know,
whatever it is,
a hundred years at some other number that's a little bit less.
You might say,
oh,
less quality but longer quality,
longer duration,
more valuable life filled in that last box.
We see how it goes.
But the question we need to ask is if we've got this more rich sense of
quantity,
where we multiplied the duration of the lifetime is the how good a life you're
having while you've got it.
Does that give adequate place to what we think is valuable?
Does that give adequate place to quality in life?
Let me draw some different boxes,
some different possible lives to choose between.
Get the,
suppose you had a nice long life,
hundred and 50 years.
Again,
just for the sake of concreteness,
we sign it 50 quality points.
So the area
7,500
let's suppose you got a feel for this.
Let's suppose that the best life lived on earth so far was worth a 10
so this is an incredible life to be at 50 and you get it for 150 years.
Very nice life.
Now compare it
with this life.
Supposedly this life isn't really all that good in terms of how well off you are
at any given time.
It's plus one
zero would be a life not worth having though no worse than nonexistence negative
numbers would be lives.
Presumably that would be,
you know,
you better off dead.
This life is just barely worth having plus one,
but it's a very,
very,
very long life.
So long that I couldn't draw it to scale.
That's why we've got the dot.
Dot.
DOTS in the middle.
Suppose it goes on for 30,000 years.
Well,
the math here is pretty easy.
30,000 Times one is 30,000 in terms of the area.
Okay,
so
trying to choose between these two lives,
life
a
or life be
in terms of quantity or enriched notion of quantity where you measure the length
of the lifetimes,
the height of the box.
Life B's got more quantity of what matters
30,000 versus 7,500 and yet most of us,
when we think about this choice,
do not find B to B a preferable life.
Even though the quantity of value sort of just suppose we could measure quantity
of whatever the goods are that we've got crammed into our life.
Well this has Mary Mary,
Mary,
small amount stretched over a very long time to quantities larger,
but life a seems preferable.
Okay.
Now for any,
Ellie,
you know,
this may not be true for everybody,
but for those of us who share that thought,
we might say quantity isn't all it's about.
Or when we tried to take quality into account,
it wasn't so much that we couldn't measure it.
It's that if you reduce the importance of quality into sort of folded into
quantity so that what it's all about is the total amount that you're getting or
the total amounts bigger and be the ne,
if you don't think B's a better life,
that suggest that totals are what it's all about.
Well,
what else might we then choose between with regard to a and B?
natural response is to say even though life a is shorter,
okay,
it attains a kind of peak,
uh,
kind of height that isn't approached any place in life be
and perhaps then in a valuating lives and choosing between rival lives.
We can't just look for the quantity of good.
We have to look at the peaks,
we have to look at the heights.
In choosing between lives.
It's important to think not just about how much did you pack in total,
but what were the greatest goods that you had or accomplished in your life
and perhaps then we should conclude quality.
Can Trump quantity
perhaps with the right quality in place quantity becomes of secondary
importance.
Yeah.
It might be that if we could have a longer life where we achieved great things
rather than a shorter life where we achieved great things better to have the
longer life quantity might matter too.
As long as we think the qualities,
what matters the most,
what a more radical version of the theory would say actually qualities.
All that matters.
The peaks are all that matter.
That at any rate is the position that gets expressed by Holderlin
in the poem to a par K to faiths.
That was in one of the essays I've had you read,
but let me,
let me read that now to the park aid.
A single summer grant me great powers and a single autumn for fully ripened song
that sated with the sweetness of my plane.
My heart may more willingly die.
The soul that living did not attain it's divine right,
cannot repose in the Netherworld,
but once what I am bent on,
what is holy,
my poetry is accomplished,
be welcomed then stillness of the shadows world.
I shall be satisfied though my layer will not accompany me down there.
Once I lived like the gods and more is not needed.
Hold,
hold.
Your lender is saying he doesn't care about quantity at all.
If he can accomplish something,
great.
If he can ascend to the heights and do something great with his poetry,
that's enough.
Once he's lived like the gods,
more is not needed.
So in thinking about what we want to do with our lives,
it's not enough to have the kind of theory that we've begun to sketch in
previous weeks where we think about what are the various things worth having in
a life.
You also have to address this question of quality versus quantity.
Is quality only important in so far as it gets folded into producing greater
quantity or does quality matter in its own right as something that's worth going
for even when it means a smaller quantity and if quality does matter,
does quantity matter as well or is indeed quality?
All that matters is Holderlin right when he says once I've lived like the gods
more is not needed
now Holderlin I imagine in thinking about why that kind of life is the best kind
of life he could aspire to
is thinking in park about the lasting contribution that his poetry makes.
There's a sense in which when we think about having done things like that,
we feel that we attain a kind of immortality we live on through our works.
And so the next question I want to turn to and sort of thinking about strategies
of how to live in light of the fact of in terms of facing our mortality is well
maybe a kind of immortality is worth going after.
No.
Or maybe at the very least we can take a kind of comfort in thinking that we
have or can attain a kind of immortality.
I emphasize the word kind of course because strictly speaking if you live on
through your works,
it's not as though you are literally living on it's semi immortality or quasar
immortality.
I suppose people who don't believe that it would prefer to call it pseudo in
mortality.
Actually this reminds me of a joke.
So here's a woody Allen joke.
Uh,
I don't want to be immortal through my work.
I want to be a mortal through not dying.
Well as know previously,
I've argued that genuine immortality,
unending life would not be a good thing,
but still many of us aspire to this kind of semi immortality and actually it can
take,
I think,
again,
two broad forms.
Sometimes people want to say there's a sense in which,
although it's not as though you're literally living on,
there's something like that going on in so far as a part of you continues.
Yeah.
If I have children,
then literally some of my,
you know,
in my case there's a male,
one of my cells continues.
Yeah.
And then their cells continue in their children and their selves continue in
their children.
Do you think of an Amoeba splitting and splitting and splitting and splitting?
Again,
parts of the original Amoeba couldn't be there for many,
many,
many generations.
Some people take comfort in the thought that literally speaking up cart of them
will continue,
if not through cells,
through my offspring.
Perhaps at least my Adams get recycled,
get used again,
and so I get absorbed into the universe,
but I never disappear.
Some people take comfort in that thought.
The German philosopher Schopenhauer thought that this should reduce somewhat the
sting of death,
he said,
but it will be asked,
how is the permanence of mere dust of crude matter to be regarded as a
continuance of our true inner nature and the answers,
Oh,
do you know this dust?
Then do you know what it is and what it can do?
Learn to know it before you despise it.
This matter now lying there as dust and ashes will soon form into crystals.
When dissolved in water,
it will shine as metal.
It will then emit electric sparks.
It will indeed of its own accord form itself into plant and animal and from its
mysterious womb,
it will develop that life I bought.
The loss of which you in your narrowness of mind are so nervous and anxious.
Okay,
well that's a very moving passage,
but I have to say I don't buy it.
I don't find any comfort at all in the thought that my atoms will still be
around getting reused into something else.
Yeah,
so this first kind of semi in mortality where you take comfort in the thought
that literally there are parts of you that will continue.
This strikes me as a kind of desperate,
striving,
desperate reaching for straws,
perhaps in Schopenhauer his case,
leading him to delude himself into thinking,
oh,
it's not so bad that I'm going to die and going to die soon.
At least my atoms will still be around.
It doesn't work for me.
There's a second sort of approach though,
where it's not so much that you're supposed to be comforted by the thought that
your parts will continue to last after you,
but that your accomplishments will continue to last after you Holderlin writes
poetry,
which we're still reading.
Some 200 years later,
you can write a novel,
which can be read for 20 or 50 or a hundred or more years.
You might make some contribution to math or philosophy or science and 50 or a
hundred years later,
people could still be talking about that philosophical argument or that
mathematical result.
You might have other kinds of accomplishments.
You might build a building that will last after you
stone cutters.
A,
I've read interviews with stone cutters who take a kind of pride and comfort in
the thought that long after they're gone,
the buildings that they helped build will still be there.
You might try to build a company that will last after you die or for that matter
you might take pleasure and comfort in the accomplishment of having raised a
family here.
Not so much the thought that you know some of yourselves are in your offspring,
but rather the thought that to have raised another decent human being is a
nontrivial accomplishment.
Something worth having done with your life and that accomplishment continues
after you are gone.
Well,
what should we think about this second group of approaches to attaining semi
immortality?
I,
I've got to say that I'm of two minds when I think about them.
I'm like the,
you know,
the dust and the Adam's stuff where I just think you're diluting yourself.
I find myself drawn to this second set of thoughts.
I find myself tempted by the thought that there's something worth doing about
producing something that continues for a while,
that it's significant.
And even if my life here on earth is a short one,
if something that I've accomplished continues my life is the better for it.
That's Holderlin thought,
I suppose.
And
okay.
It,
it's a view that appeals to me.
I suppose it explains in part why I write philosophy in the hopes that the
things I write might still be red 20 years after I die,
or 50 years or if I'm so lucky a hundred years after I die.
Okay.
Well,
in certain moods,
perhaps in most moods I'm drawn by that thought.
But in other moods I've got to confess,
I'm skeptical of it.
I remind myself of Schopenhauer writing,
his little passage has owed to dust.
And I find myself saying just like Schopenhauer was so desperate that he deludes
himself into thinking,
oh,
it doesn't matter that I'm about to turn into dust.
Dust is really,
really important.
Uh,
I'm just diluting myself as well when I think there's something grander,
something significant,
something valuable about having made an accomplishment,
having achieved something that continues beyond me.
So an in certain moods,
at least I find myself thinking that I've just diluted myself.
Okay.
But that's the only certain moods and at least most of the time I find myself in
agreement with Holderlin.
Not necessarily in thinking,
you know,
quantity doesn't matter at all to have written,
one great work is all you need and more great works,
doesn't add anything that strikes me is going too far,
but at least to have done something significant that abides.
That does seem to me to add to the value and significance of my life.
Well,
yeah,
let me mention an entire different approach.
I'm going to get very,
very short shrift to this last approach,
but it's probably worth mentioning as well the,
the entire assumption of all the lines of thought that I've been discussing.
Okay.
So far today having common,
the underlying belief
that
the way to deal with the fact that we live
okay
and then we're dead,
is to try to make the life that you've got as good as possible,
as valuable as possible to pack as much into it as you can,
even though there's room for disagreement about what's the best strategy for
doing that.
Okay.
The picture is one in which we say we can't do anything about the loss.
The loss of life.
So the the right response is to,
okay,
make the life that we've got is valuable as it can be to see it as valuable as
it can be,
but there's a rather different approach that,
that,
that that alternative approach says,
yes,
we're going to lose life and,
and that's horrible,
but it's only a horrible in so far as you think of life as something that it's
bad to lose.
After all,
if we were to decide that life wasn't really a valuable gift,
if it wasn't really something worth embracing it and something that we could
turn into something full of value,
then it's loss wouldn't actually be a loss.
That's a part we've seen before,
right?
The central badness of death is explained in the deprivation account.
You are deprived of the fact that you could have had more life that would have
been worth having overall,
but if life isn't worth having overall,
then it's lost.
It's not a bad thing but a good thing.
The trick then isn't to make life as valuable as it couldn't be,
but rather to come to recognize that I'm balanced.
Life isn't positive but negative.
I know that when I'm about to say has a kind of classics illustrated simplicity
to it and it's a bit of an over exaggeration,
but in gross terms we might say the first general outlook that life is good and
so the loss of it is bad and so the answer is make as much of it as we can.
While we've got it might say that is in broad strokes,
the western outlook.
Yeah,
and in broad strokes,
the notion that life
isn't really as good as we take it to be buddies in fact bad overall.
Perhaps it's oversimplification to call it the eastern outlook,
but at least it's an outlook that gets more expression typically in eastern
thought than in western thought.
For most example of this.
Second Outlook is I suppose Buddhism
four noble truth in Buddhism.
The first noble truth is that life is suffering.
Buddhists believe if you think hard about the underlying nature of life,
you'll see that every place there is loss,
there is suffering,
there's disease,
there's death,
there's pain,
sure there are things that we want and if we're lucky we get them but then we
lose them and that just adds to the suffering and the pain and the misery.
I'm balanced.
Life isn't good first noble truth,
life is suffering and so armed with this estimation,
what Buddhist try to do is to free you from attachment to these goods so that
when you lose them
the loss is minimized and indeed Buddhist try to free you from what they take to
be the illusion of there being itself.
There is no need to lose anything.
Death is terrifying in so far as I worry about about it being the dissolution of
myself.
If there is no self,
there's nothing to dissolve.
Okay.
It all makes sense.
And I have tremendous respect for Buddhism.
It all makes sense given the thought that life is suffering.
Yeah.
But for better or for worse,
I'm a child of the West.
I'm a child of the book of Genesis where God looks on the world and says it's
good.
For me at least,
the strategy of minimize your loss by viewing the world as negative is not one
that I can be at rest with.
For me,
life can be good.
And so the s the choices for me,
and I suppose for most of us remain among the strategy strategies with which I
began.
How is it that we can most make our lives valuable?
What is it that we can do that will allow us with Holderlin to say once we lived
like the gods.